[Music]
welcome back to science click today
Einstein's gravity in the 17th century
Newton discovers universal gravitation
with this he manages to predict the
movement of an apple falling from a tree
or the orbit of the moon around the
earth
however Newton does not manage to
explain why gravity exists
nor how it acts to answer these
questions it is necessary to wait for
the early 20th century with Albert
Einstein's theory of general relativity
for Einstein the three dimensions of
space in which we move and time in which
we evolve are just two parts of a same
thing space-time in space-time objects
exists in a given place at a given time
now let us try to conceptualize
space-time as a grid on which we could
place an object a when a is placed on
this grid it distorts it according to
its mass the more massive the object the
more it will distort space-time
inversely the less massive the less
space-time will be disturbed now let's
imagine that we place a second object b
on this grid b distorts space-time as
well since it possesses a mass but less
than a since its mass is not as great
let's now look at what happens if we
release a marble in a bowl because of
the bowls curvature the marble will
slide along the inside of it until it
comes to rest at the center in a similar
way when we think about space-time in
distorting the grid a creates a sort of
bowl around itself consequently just
like a marble B will slide along this
bowl gradually edging closer to a if we
look at this scene from above we observe
that B is attracted by a just like with
Newton's model of gravity now if we were
to release B in this bowl with a certain
speed it would go around the bowl while
getting closer to a finally if we could
release B with a sufficiently great
speed B would begin to go around a
without ever getting closer to it it is
in this way that planets orbits around
the Sun just like with Newton
Einstein's theory predicts the movement
of planets around the Sun however being
more thorough this theory has also
enabled the discovery of many other
scientific novelties like the fact that
a very important density can lead to the
appearance of what we call a black hole
[Music]
[Music]